good evening and thank you so much for
joining us here at five i'm christian
casadis we'll get to our new year's
coverage in just a moment but first
breaking news from the las vegas strip a
deadly shooting at the fashion show and
also a shooting at the meadows mall
shortly after let's begin with madison
kimbrough she joins us live from fashion
show mall with what may have led up to
the shooting madison
police believe the shooting happened
during a robbery here around 1 30 this
afternoon take a look as we are right by
the scene inside the parking garage near
the dillards at fashion show police say
a couple who had been shopping was
approached while inside the parking
garage by a white or hispanic male who
attempted to rob them after an initial
struggle the suspect shot the woman in
the chest that woman who was in her 60s
later died after being transported to
umc
as for the husband he is currently with
police no word if he suffered any
serious injuries the suspect who again
is said to be either a white or hispanic
male between 5 11 and 6-2 remains on the
run there is still a heavy police
presence here and homicide detectives
will be here for a while keep it here on
8 news now as we learn the latest
details reporting live at fashion show
madison kimbrough live local now